est ce que tu veux qu'on passe contrée
cadets mais moi j'adore suicide
[Applaudissements]
on est arrivé je me dis juste là on est
arrivé à un stade de l'émission où il ya
trop d'invités tu avais je suis ensuite
abordé pour comprendre à quel point
cyril hanouna rend les gens heureux
j'étais manger avec ma grand mère dans
une crêperie à paris et je lui ai rien
dit et je sais qu'elle regarde cyril
tous les soirs je lui ai rien dit j'ai
dit à sir et vient me voir à la crêperie
et il est venu à la crêperie et ma
grand-mère en crêpe toile était pas en
effet anti fin en aimant pas le fromage
est bien là vu cyril à la kiffer à la
diam où elle a vu tu vois et je elle m'a
dit mais qu'est ce qu'il fait là j'ai
dit venus me voir l'entreprise
elle m'a dit ah ça ça veut dire c'est le
showbiz j'ai vu le film sombre c'est de
la bombe non mais c'est vrai très très
joli et merci frère hoarau contre encore
à huy autre chose
c'est à chaque film qui montre l on
dirait qu'il a cinquante mille facettes
mais je vais jusqu'au bout d'attila non
mais ils sont rigolos et gentiment série
très beau merci beaucoup à tout cas
merci beaucoup pour le film c'est vrai
qu'on a pris beaucoup de plaisir à le
faire on s'est éclatés et c'est vrai que
c'est une vraie comédie romantique un
peu anglo saxonne mais française donc
c'était un vrai bonheur de travailler
là-dessus et c'est vrai qu'on a rarement
on voit des films ou pour des films que
ça le dernier film que j'avais vu comme
ça moi un peu à l'anglo saxonne c'était
le film avec sophie marceau et gad
elmaleh à la comédie que j'ai vu aussi
romantique avec notre peau de gad et ça
faisait longtemps que j'avais pas vu
venir ni temps ouais c'est ça pour vous
dire
donc c'était la piété la dernière fois
que j'ai vu une comédie
qu'est ce que l'art c'est la mécano fini
[Rires]
merde
peut ne pas parler de l'émission pendant
deux ans et juste électrocuté pour le
alors merci mais ça c'est bon et au pcb
artères font plaisir qu'est ce qu'être
j'ai été surprise en toi qu'on construit
ça me fait plaisir et est ce que c'était
bien quelqu'un était venu le voir c'est
pas vrai c'est une surprise pour toi
est-ce que tu mon vélo hinault par nous
et on ouvre le rideau
oui si c'est une mauvaise surprise très
bien sûr j'aimerais à nadi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas mal
sincèrement clôturer cette émission dans
l'amour ac c'est le seul grand père qui
me reste c'est une bombe
il est gentil il est intelligent il est
beau il il est un exemple pour tout
l'amour aussi du bruit bond à nez rouge
est apparemment 6,10 à certaines
demandes
vous avez envie de le voir encore plus
je le voulais mais chez nous à notre
table malheureusement assez pas
malheureusement il a beaucoup de travail
tout le temps on l'excusé faire donner
très fier de lui et vraiment il est très
méritant parce que vraiment ils
travaillent beaucoup et la voir à notre
table ce serait une joie et non je suis
dit l'avoir plus souvent un autre si je
te dis je viendrai vient jeter 10 jeux
vidéo ou tafer a pris du café mais c'est
pas suffisant